we'll talk with talks are unstructured
videos in which we discussed and explore
ideas about all things animate enjoy hey
guys Anna Mack here and I'm here with
goals end today and we'll be discussing
anime as a medium
you know what makes anime is so unique
why is it so popular around the world
what makes it different from other
mediums and you know why that matters
the first thing that comes to my mind
you know and I'm sure you've experienced
it as well if you tell someone you're an
anime fan especially in the West you'll
get people saying what you you watch
cartoons you like cartoons isn't that
for kids like even my own parents you
know get surprised that as an adult I
still watch cartoons right so they
because they think it's for kids they
think Bugs Bunny Tom and Jerry that kind
of stuff and it's you know you really
gotta explain it to them to your friends
to your parents who don't understand
animate why anime is still interesting
even if you're you know older than 10
right so the first thing you have to do
is explain well not all anime is Pokemon
not all anime is Digimon
there are anime out there for mature
people mature anime that deal with
serious topics and issues and you know
often graphic violence is included and
all these things and so it's basically
like a serious Hollywood movie or an HBO
series right but I think the big
advantage that anime has compared to
Hollywood movies and series and things
like that is that the issue of budgets
if you think about how much money you
need to create a Hollywood film
sometimes hundreds of millions of
dollars a successful film or a series in
order to achieve that you really have to
make sure that it appeals to a wide
group of people right it has to be very
popular you know it has to be pop so you
know this limits the director the writer
in terms of what they can do because not
everyone's gonna love everything not
everyone loves philosophy or you know
literature or whatever these complex
issues so often you get you know like a
big superhero movie and action and
fighting and
kind of it kind of uh it's all on the
surface it's all the same I think the
real advantage of anime is because it's
animated the budget concerns are far
less you know far more down on the list
of priorities right because in terms of
animation budget you can do so much more
into the animation you know space wars
and fantasy and all this kind of stuff
with much less money so I think that's a
huge issue because in order to do that
you know in 3d in Hollywood or
live-action you're gonna be talking
hundreds of millions of dollars if
you're doing it in in terms of an
animated series it's gonna be much less
expensive so you what that means is what
I'm trying to get at is that you don't
have to appeal to everyone you don't
have to appeal to like a huge audience
in order to still make sure that anime
is profitable because you can make a
sci-fi anime that's you know deals with
philosophy and all this kind of things
something like ergo proxy for example
and even if it you know I limited am
audience likes it and enjoys it and buys
it you're still gonna be okay because
you didn't spend that much money on it
but if you're making a Hollywood film
equivalent of Ergo Proxy and you are a
lot of people don't like it you end up
losing a lot of money so you know you're
never gonna do that again you're gonna
get fired the studio's is never gonna
let it the studio's will never let that
happen right so I think that really
makes if you could get past the whole 2d
animation stuff which some people seem
to not be able to hear in the West if
you can get past that and actually look
at the quality this is really an amazing
advantage with on a smaller budget you
can do a lot more you can explore old
explore all these different issues you
don't have to worry too much about it
appealing to everyone although of course
we do have a lot of mainstream anime
that do appeal to everyone and all that
kind of stuff but I think this is really
a key strength for anime so goes and
what do you think you have any thoughts
on this why is anime is such a unique
medium and why it doesn't have so many
fans around the world outside of Japan
in Japan
stuff well he says a good point that you
know it lets you take more risks it lets
you use money better yeah use money
better no I like that I like that it's
it's like succinct right but what I
actually think is even more important is
just the sheer possibility because some
things that they could do with 2d
animation is not only expensive
sometimes it's impossible with non 2d
animation so you can really let your
imagination run wild you can whatever
you can think of you can put on that
screen and as someone who enjoys Emprise
of self on imagination I feel like it's
the best tool if not the only tool that
I've seen that can fully express what's
going on in an artist's mind on
screening yeah that's I think that's a
good point I'm like in terms of medium
or media I think that after books anime
is probably the best medium out there
even better than movies even better than
you know Hollywood series whatever
because you know books are not a visual
medium
they make you visualize so when you read
a book if you read a good book it's
really giving you all this kind of
information you know when you if you've
seen a movie based on a book and then
you read the book here it meant the book
is so much better it's because it lets
you do things on your own it lets you
you know visualize things make your own
decisions about what the characters look
like all this kind of stuff and there's
so much more detail so much more going
on because they can't put all that on
the screen now with anime I feel like
because it's a series so often it can be
little longer dozens of episodes and
because they have this kind of less of a
limit in terms of budgets they're able
to really come closer to reading a good
book for example then Hollywood movies
Hollywood series things like that right
and so I think that in that sense really
after books after really
books anime is my next favorite medium
ahead of all these Hollywood things and
popular show TV shows or series or films
and so on
yeah we can't overlook the fact that
though maybe books is a more favorite
medium at the same time anime offers a
lot of things that books don't yeah it's
actually that actually you can add maybe
a different but in some way is a better
experience because of the visual art
which a lot of people are more visually
stimulated than they are textually also
you can add music oh yoga so all those
and obviously there's always the story
that's being written by the writers so
what I love about anime which is not so
much the case with books although I love
books is that you're taking all these
different mediums almost all these
different forms of art and you're
combining them in a way that works in
harmony together and it creates
something that you can't have with just
one medium right which i think is one of
the biggest strengths of anime that you
can combine all these different mediums
and create something new something great
yeah I think the music stuff is really
key point there because you know if you
look at anime that's really heavily
influenced by music like Jun my a does
anime or something like Nodame cantabile
you really see that you know the music
and play a key role just accompanying
the visual art in kind of giving you a
richer experience of course with books
you don't have the visual and and you
know audio you do music working together
you have to you know you're reading and
you're imagining things on your own and
that's great but you're right I think
that
anime really offers a unique experience
in this sense because it can combine you
know this visual beauty with this
musical harmony and at a lower budget
that's not he
of West considered mainstream to because
you know when I watch Hollywood movies
and series you know there are some good
ones I gotta say you know you have your
Game of Thrones is and your house of
cards and you know really good series
and end the films but by and large I
feel like you know when you watch a
Hollywood movie on mainstream Hollywood
movie you know it's been there done that
I've seen this before
anime is really unique like it's it's
kind of stuff that you don't see in
anime you don't mean if you look at Nagi
ah sue you have us village under the sea
and people breathing under the sea and
you know living there and just existing
alongside regular people like that's
really creative but like the visuals
that creates and like just that like
kind of magical realism set up like
you're not gonna see that in mainstream
Hollywood movies maybe in like of like
you know one of those independent films
gonna that are considered artsy but you
know anime really is kind of our de la
Mer red okay yes but they're mermaids
right it's like it's understood that
they're mermaids
they don't know humans don't know about
them with Nagas yeah so like they all
know about each other is just like
normal right it's normal that they exist
that way and and yeah I just really
created really cool and I find that
anime is really kind of trend setting
which is why I think a lot of Hollywood
movies like The Matrix or Inception
inception right are actually influenced
pre confluence inception yet so yeah so
it's like they're actually influenced
Hollywood the really good Hollywood
movies are actually looking at anime for
inspiration because they're so creative
because it's so established over the
years that you know there's they're
doing things differently so yeah and I'm
still waiting for that Death Note movie
I mean whether they should make it
should be like the discussion on a
different video because that would be
stuff say about that but even even
thinking about honey and clover for
example with the visual art I know it
definitely turned Anna back off that
kind of visuals and it will turn some
people off but they're not trying to be
let's say make the characters look
extremely aesthetically pleasing as they
are in code geass let's say where
everyone
looks amazing but it is definitely more
artistic and that's something what I
like about honey and clover it's it's so
not mainstream that you can you can
really appreciate how different it is
and you see they do a lot of
experimental stuff on the screen where
let's say a flower falls in the middle
of the screen and it follows it in slow
motion and even expressionistic
techniques that you don't see in real
movies and sometimes you can't even do
in real movies so looking at gems like
that which really push the edges of what
you can do with visual art is I think
the strength of anime and many unique
anime is you know many things to goes
and for his like whole philosophical I'm
Socrates analysis of art oh yeah that's
that's goes in for you but okay guys I
think that uh we've had a good
discussion here let us know what you
think about this and you know do you
have trouble explaining to people around
you if you're in the West especially why
you love anime why it's why it's not
just for kids uh you know send us your
comment send us in the comments some of
your experiences how you deal with it
and yeah if you want to tell us what you
thought of our comments and arguments
and if you want to use these comments
and arguments to kind of argue with
people who don't want to give an Emmy a
chance
be our guest and let us know how it goes
and and even point out the fact that if
you have something else we missed point
it out we may discuss in a different
video because we'll definitely be
reading the comments yeah yeah we don't
have anything else to do that's all we
do but yeah okay so make sure you
subscribe for more videos make sure you
comment let us know what you think and
that's about it I will see you next time
on the next video see ya
change
lies